hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we're going to be
looking at the endgame king and rook
first king and it's very similar to the
king and queen in game as we're
basically going to try to bring our rook
and minimize the squares that the black
king can go to and just continue to
march our rook up the board until the
black king is checkmated so we'll go
ahead and take a look what that looks
like first move we're going to move rook
to e7 and you can already see we've
already limited the black King to these
three files the F file the G file in the
H file so the black King can only move
in these spots and let's say the black
king moves to g5 he's now limited his
space even more we can just bring our
rook to two f7 and we've already now
limited the King to two files that you
found the H file now let's say the black
King continues and attacks are our oak
obviously we're not going to come down
to the G file now but then we can simply
bring our rook down to F one away from
the danger of the black Kings attack and
the black King is still limited to these
two files the G file an H file obviously
the black King is going to continue to
come down if he does move back to the H
file then we can simply bring our rook
even closer and limit the moves so more
than likely you'll see the black King
starts to come towards your rook now we
can bring our white King into the mix
and if black continues down now we can
simply bring our route 2 G 1 and this is
this situation right here is what you
want if you ever want to force black to
move back a file or Road depending on
which set if you have this is kind of
what you want you want the King in the
both Kings looking at each other with
one space in between and you want your
rook bring it to the file that the King
the black King is on and the black king
is forced to move he can't come to F 5 F
4 F 3 because the King and he had can't
move along the G file because of the
rook here so he's forced to move back to
the H file and when he does move you can
see he's limited to the H file here
because of our rook on the G file so
from here you may see from here we're
simply going to bring our King into the
mix obviously we want our King if it's
our move right here it'd be checkmate we
go to h1 but we want to bring our King
into the mix our H our rook is on a
great square already so we're going to
go ahead and leave that there from here
black is going to move obviously his
only chances to come and attack our rook
and right away we're just going to move
our rook so that he can't come any
closer so we're going to go ahead and
bring our rook to g8 it doesn't matter
if you do it in a couple moves it's not
going to make a big difference I'm going
to go ahead and get it out of harm's way
because now if he tries to come back and
come to our rook let's say to h5 then we
can simply move to H a they will be
checkmate because that's the situation
that we want so he's probably not going
to do that you'll probably see the black
King run away and then we can simply
start marching our King down the board
chasing them if he ever moves back again
we can just move our rook to h8 it's
going to be checkmate but it's going to
be checkmate eventually anyway so black
continues to move back down the board we
continue marching he moves to h1 and
from here we can simply move our King to
f2 and then his only move is to move
back to h2 and we can simply move
rook to H a checkmate so this is the
easy way to checkmate a king with your
king and rook hope you guys enjoyed if
you haven't already please subscribe
thanks for watching the video see you
guys next time